you don't like gloves don't love gloves
worming your hand into a glove i'm just
like ha ha
i don't like it but wait did you wear
gloves in mary poppins didn't you yeah
and it was tough
it was tough i'm not gonna lie i took
them off whenever i could really was it
tough it was really cool it was
really tough for you it's really tough
for me it's really hard really hard you
should toughen up
hi everyone i'm dwayne johnson hey
everybody i am unfortunately emily blunt
you're welcome
i'm jack whitehall and i am going to be
hosting a little game of do you even
know me
for unilad i hope i don't know you
what is dwayne's signature wrestling
move is it
a the man's shoulder is it b
the people's elbow or is it c the
gentleman's reach around
it's the people's elbows it's gone
[Applause]
hey jack could you show us what the c
looks like
what is c i don't know what it is
so you're in a squat and through the
legs that's a lot
you squat and you just snake round and
that's not very gentlemanly it seems
quite aggressive
you say sorry as you do it that's why
it's called the gentleman's retreat
according to imdb emily has a fear of
what
cats gloves or physical intimacy
[Laughter]
oh my god uh
it would be well she wore gloves she
already wore gloves and married pop-pop
so i would go with uh cats no i don't
like gloves
you don't like gloves don't love gloves
i don't like that
squeezing your hands oh you don't oh you
don't like those feel uh
claustrophobic like plastic gloves any
glove worming your hand into a glove i'm
just like ha ha i don't like it
but wait did you wear gloves in mary
poppins didn't you yeah and it was tough
it was tough i'm not gonna lie i took
them off whenever i could really was it
tough
it was really cool it was really tough
for you it's really tough for me it's
really hard
really hard really hot you should
toughen up
uh question for emily yes in 2016
dwayne was voted what by people magazine
he never mentions this it's going to be
hard
i never it funny because he's never
brought it up so it's very nice he's
never brought it up so i don't know how
you would get this this is impossible
yes man alive unfortunately it really
was that is that is the truth it won't
stop until you feed them
i want you to just know that you are a
real actor
and you do not need to make your tits
downs anymore for anyone
that's how i got my roles making my
disciples that's it
that's how we got them that's how we got
the role in jungle cruise
little tip bounce yes correct you're
welcome dwayne was voted
the sexiest man live in 2016. john
krasinski came fifth that year
and i was voted number 157th one place
below boris johnson
tough year question for dwayne emily was
in a girl band
at school what were they called a
harmonious
b goddesses of sound c
that is it should have been that it was
definitely harmonious
yeah it was yeah it was correct right
correct answer yeah
how long did that ban by the way it
really we we only had we only managed
one song it was tlc
don't go chasing waterfalls it was an
absolute classic it brought the house
down at ibstock place school
brought the house and ironically you've
ignored the advice of tlc and in this
movie you do go chasing multiples
question for emily to the nearest 10
million and again
it's not something that dj has ever
mentioned how many followers does train
have
never oh it's all you talk about i
never mentioned that didn't you get the
number added to the tattoo
of the book i never mentioned it about
210
million oh come on oh my god no i never
mentioned and
i don't count it's 255 million wow i
mean whatever
is it really it's so many that's gone up
a million since this card was printed
it's true
it's true oh 256 now guys i don't i
don't count just the most followed
american in the world
listen it's gross it's gross move on
next question
so oh god delivered i signed for it this
is your new favorite and you and your
generosity never quite get to laugh
now
it never does it never does you keep
pushing it out there
and it it sort of goes quite quiet quiet
god delivers outside guys
silence silence okay anyone watching
please
just go online now follow selena gomez
let's just knock him down knock him down
a peg
got delivered i signed guys no please
one more one more come on let's do one
more it's too fun
question for emily what was dwayne's
nickname as a child
was it a pickles b dewey
or c sweet sweet baby johnson
i mean that's what you call him sweet
sweets
but i know it's dewey wow good
correct for a bonus point his nickname
as an adult
is tuts
[Laughter]
so to wrap things up for unilad
emily is the winner of the game she
knows more about dwayne
than dwayne knows about because dwayne
has more instagram followers
so i guess he's the winner really jack
come on you are a
go suck-up we'll continue to play the
game
we're gonna continue to play the game
see you around
come on okay okay i got it uh five six
five five no five four five four but
in in in centimeters what am i i don't
even know what that is in inches
how tall am i in centimeters 32 no